hi everyone its Johanna here hours in
the gym the other day and they were
doing a squat challenge and so I thought
I would like to share it with you and
this will be our challenge for the month
the song is called flower by Moby and it
is also the OST for gone in 60 seconds
so it's a three and a half minutes squat
challenge no stopping and it's really
good to turn the entire lower body up
and also to really give you a nice legs
this is really good to turn up your
thighs and if you can do it every day
and I can guarantee you in three to four
weeks time you will definitely see
results so let's start a challenge so
before we begin I would like to make
sure that you're standing right toes
facing forward knees facing forward
shoulder-width apart squat down push
your bum out and up so when the music
stays green Sally up that's when you're
upright and ready save green set it down
then swing it down okay so green Sally
up up green set it down down ready let
me put the music on and three and a half
minutes challenge
do not stop
can you hear it
only Twitter confidence keep going
good
yup
you're about to do this every day
because
that's it
I'll see it
three weddings that's it
via mice
yes
and going
pulse pulse pulse pulse good good very
good
hopfully them
it
this is really gonna blow applying life
that's good
innovate
pretty go low holy pulse pulse
Oh see Paul's good almost at the end
good we go low come on cheese yes
yes
tranquilo
very good job
again
randomize
come on let's go
come on pulse pulse pulse oh good job
remember to download the music put it on
your iPhone or your iPod and do it
whenever you can it's just three and a
half minutes but it would really give
you the nice thighs you want quick so
whether you're waiting for food to cook
do it listen to it put it on your iPod
and just do it for three and a half
minutes or whether you just go a little
bit to it as well wherever you can't
okay that's my challenge to you for the
month and the more you do it the easier
my it is so let me know how you get on
and don't forget to subscribe to my page
like it share it for more nutritional
and fitness tips bye